La primera vez que supe de la comunidad copta
fue en 2009 cuando las autoridades de Egipto bajo el régimen de Hosni Mubarak
decidieron sacrificar 300 000 cerdos bajo el pretexto del virus H1N1.
Originalmente, son criadores de cerdos.
Sus cerdos y otros animales son alimentados con desecho orgánico
que es recolectado diariamente.
Este hecho terminó con su sustento.
La primera vez que entré a Manshiyat Naser, parecía un laberinto.
Estaba buscando el Monasterio de San Simón en lo alto de la Montaña Muqattam.
A la derecha, luego a la derecha de nuevo, a la izquierda
para llegar a lo más alto.
Pero para llegar ahí, tienes que eludir los camiones sobrecargados de basura
y escurrirte entre los tuk-tuks,
el vehículo más rápido para moverte por el vecindario.
El olor de la basura descargada de esos camiones era intenso,
y el del tráfico era fuerte y apabullante.
Sumen el estruendo de las trituradoras en esos almacenes del camino.
Desde fuera parece caótico, pero todo está perfectamente organizado.
Los zaraeeb, que es como se autodenominan
y que significa criadores de cerdos,
han recolectado la basura de El Cairo
y la han organizado en su propio barrio desde hace décadas.
Ellos han desarrollado uno de los sistemas más eficientes
y altamente rentables a nivel mundial.
Aún así, el lugar se percibe tan sucio, marginado y segregado
por su asociación con la basura.
Así que mi idea inicial era crear una pieza anamórfica,
una pieza que solo se puede ver desde un punto de vista.
Quería desafiarme artísticamente pintando sobre varios edificios
y hacerlo totalmente visible desde un punto de la montaña Muqattam.
La montaña de Muqattam es el orgullo de la comunidad.
Aquí se construyó el Monasterio de San Simón,
una iglesia en una gruta para 10 000 asientos tallada en la propia montaña.
La primera vez me puse de pie en la cima de la montaña
y miré el barrio,
y me pregunté ¿cómo voy a convencer a todos esos propietarios
para que me dejen pintar sus edificios?
Y entonces llegó Magd.
Magd es un guía de la iglesia.
Me dijo que a la única persona que tenía que convencer era al padre Samaan,
el líder de la comunidad.
Pero para convencer al padre Samaan, tenía que convencer a Mario,
un artista polaco que se mudó a El Cairo hace 20 años
y creó todo el material gráfico de la iglesia de la gruta.
Le agradezco mucho a Mario. Él fue la clave del proyecto.
Se las arregló para conseguirme una reunión con el padre Samaan,
y, sorprendentemente, le gustaba la idea.
Me preguntó dónde pinté antes
y cómo lo iba a hacer.
Y le preocupaba principalmente lo que yo iba a escribir.
En toda obra que hago, escribo mensajes
con mi estilo de caligrafía árabe.
Me aseguro de que esos mensajes sean relevantes en el lugar donde pinto
pero tienen una dimensión universal,
así que cualquiera en todo el mundo puede identificarse con eso.
Así que para Manshiyat Naser,
decidí escribir en árabe las palabras de San Atanasio de Alejandría,
un obispo copto del siglo III, que dijo:
(Árabe) Quien quiera ver la luz del sol con claridad, debe secarse los ojos.
que en español significa:
"Quien quiera ver la luz del sol con claridad
primero debe secarse los ojos".
Fue muy importante para mí
que la comunidad se conectara con las palabras.
Y para mí esta cita refleja perfectamente el espíritu del proyecto.
Así que el padre Samaan bendijo el proyecto,
y su aprobación atrajo a todos los residentes a bordo.
Cientos de litros de pintura, una docena de ascensores manuales azules,
varios viajes de ida y vuelta a El Cairo,
un equipo fuerte y sólido de Francia, Norte de África, Oriente Medio y EE.UU.,
y después de un año de planificación y logística, allí estamos,
mi equipo y algunos miembros de la comunidad local
crearon una obra repartida en 50 edificios,
que abarca el espacio de la caligrafía
que tracé con colores.
Aquí algo de azul, algo de amarillo, algo de naranja.
Otros llevan bolsas de arena
y las ponen en la cima de los edificios
para sostener los ascensores manuales,
y otros ensamblan y desensamblan esos mismos ascensores
y los mueven por los distintos edificios.
Al comienzo del proyecto,
numeré esos edificios en mi bosquejo,
y no había interacción real con la comunidad.
La gente no entendía la idea de todo esto.
Pero pronto esos números de edificios se convierten en nombres familiares.
El primer edificio era la casa del tío Ibrahim.
El tío Ibrahim es una persona muy entusiasta.
Siempre cantando y haciendo chistes,
y sus hijas e hijos me salvaron de su toro
que quiso atacarme en la cuarta planta.
(Risas)
En realidad, el toro me vio desde la ventana y salió al balcón.
Sí.
El tío Ibrahim siempre estaba en el balcón
y me hablaba mientras yo pintaba.
Recuerdo que dijo que no fue a la montaña durante 10 años,
y que nunca se tomaba un día libre.
Dijo que si él dejaba de trabajar, ¿quién detendría la basura?
Pero, sorprendentemente, al final del proyecto,
hizo todo el camino a la montaña para mirar la obra.
Estaba muy orgulloso de ver su casa pintada,
y dijo que este proyecto era un proyecto de paz y...
lo siento...
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Dijo que se trataba de un proyecto de paz y unidad
y que unía a la gente.
Por lo que su percepción hacia el proyecto cambió,
y también cambió mi percepción hacia la comunidad,
y hacia lo que hacen.
Toda la basura que a todo el mundo disgusta, no es de ellos.
Ellos solo trabajan con eso.
En realidad, no viven en la basura. Ellos viven de la basura.
Así que empecé a dudar de mí mismo y a preguntarme
cuál era el verdadero propósito de todo este proyecto.
No se trataba de embellecer un lugar por medio del arte.
Se trataba de cambiar la percepción y abrir un diálogo
en la conexión que tenemos con comunidades que no conocemos.
Así, día tras día,
el círculo de la caligrafía tomaba forma,
y siempre nos encantaba volver en la montaña para ver la obra.
Y pararme allí todos los días me hizo dar cuenta
del simbolismo que hay detrás de esta obra amorfa.
Si uno quiere ver la imagen real de alguien,
quizá deba cambiar su ángulo.
Había dudas y dificultades,
como miedos y estrés.
No fue sencillo trabajar en ese entorno,
a veces había cerdos debajo de uno mientras que pintaba
o subiendo una pila de basura para llegar a un ascensor.
Pero todos superamos el miedo a las alturas, al balanceo del andamio,
a los olores fuertes
y también el estrés de no terminar a tiempo.
La bondad de todas esas personas nos hizo olvidar todo.
El edificio número 3 era la casa del tío Bakheet y la tía Fareeda.
En árabe hay esa expresión que dice: "ahsen nas",
que significa "la mejor gente".
Ellos eran la mejor gente.
Solíamos tomar nuestro descanso en frente de sus casas,
y todos los niños del barrio
solían venir.
Estaba impresionado y sorprendido por los niños de Manshiyat Naser.
Los primeros días, rechazaban cualquier cosa que les ofrecíamos,
incluso alimentos o bebidas.
Le pregunté a la tía Fareeda: "¿Por qué es eso?"
Y ella me dijo que le enseñan a sus hijos a rechazar todo
de alguien a quien no conocen
porque tal vez esa persona lo necesita más que ellos.
En realidad, en ese exacto momento me di cuenta
de que la comunidad Zaraeeb era el contexto ideal
para tratar el tema de la percepción.
Tenemos que cuestionar nuestras ideas erróneas
y el juicio que tenemos como sociedad
sobre las comunidades con base en las diferencias.
Recuerdo cómo nos retrasamos en la casa del tío Ibrahim
cuando sus cerdos que se crían en el techo
nos comían las bolsas de arena que sostienen los ascensores.
(Risas)
La casa del tío Bakheet y la tía Fareeda
era el punto de encuentro.
Todo el mundo solía reunirse allí.
Creo que esto es lo que quería decir el tío Ibrahim
cuando dijo que era un proyecto de paz y unidad,
porque realmente sentí que las personas se unían.
Todo el mundo nos saludaba con una sonrisa, nos ofrecía una bebida
o nos invitaba a su propia casa para el almuerzo.
A veces, uno está en el primer nivel de un edificio,
y alguien abre la ventana y le ofrece un té.
Y lo mismo ocurre en el segundo piso.
Y así uno sigue hasta el techo.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Creo que nunca tomé tanto té como en Egipto.
(Risas)
Y para ser honesto, podríamos haber terminado antes,
pero nos llevó tres semanas por todos esos descansos para el té.
(Risas)
En Egipto, tienen otra expresión, que es "nawartouna",
que significa, "nos trajiste luz".
En Manshiyat Naser siempre nos decían eso.
La caligrafía, en realidad...
para la caligrafía usé una pintura blanca que resplandece en la oscuridad
así que al final del proyecto, alquilamos unos proyectores de luz negra
e iluminamos todo el barrio,
sorprendiendo a los vecinos.
Queríamos decirles
que ellos son quienes nos trajeron luz a nosotros.
(Aplausos)
La comunidad Zaraeeb es fuerte, honesta, muy trabajadora,
y saben lo que valen.
Los habitantes de El Cairo los llaman "los zabaleen"
que significa "la gente de la basura",
pero, irónicamente, la gente de Manshiyat Naser
llama a la gente de El Cairo "los zabaleen".
Dicen, que allí producen la basura, y no en Manshiyat Naser.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
El objetivo era dejar algo a esta comunidad,
pero siento que ellos son los que dejaron algo en nuestras vidas.
El proyecto artístico era solo un pretexto
para esta experiencia humana increíble.
La obra de arte en algún momento desaparecerá, se desvanecerá,
y, en realidad, alguien está construyendo un segundo piso
frente a la casa del tío Ibrahim,
cubriendo parte de la pintura,
así que puede que tenga que volver y pintar allí.
(Risas)
Tuvo que ver con la experiencia,
con la historia,
con el momento.
Desde las calles del barrio
la pintura aparece en fragmentos
aislados uno de otro,
separados.
Pero conectados bajo el signo de la caligrafía
aún hoy revela el mensaje potente en el que todos debemos pensar
antes de juzgar a alguien.
Quien quiera ver la luz del sol con claridad
primero debe secarse los ojos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)